[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public c'est
parti pour 90 minutes de débats et de
reportage et voici le sommaire de ce 19
juin deux Français sur trois souhaitent
le départ d'Elizabeth borne et 56 % de
nos compatriotes appellent de leur vœux
une alliance entrée même Macron et le
parti LR mais cette hypothèse semble
toujours improbable on vous explique les
blocages les tractations qui continuent
au sein de la majorité présidentielle et
la stratégie médiatique des ans des
prétendants à Matignon ce sera juste
après ces titres et puis dans 45 minutes
direction les États-Unis pour retrouver
un ex président inculpé par un tribunal
fédéral c'est une première dans
l'histoire américaine c'était la semaine
dernière et Donald Trump criait au
complot politique
plus important encore il s'agit d'une
persécution politique digne d'une nation
fasciste ou communiste
Trump visé par 37 chefs d'incubation
dans le dossier des archives protégés de
la Maison Blanche cette affaire
peut-elle l'empêcher d'être candidat aux
primaire républicaines comment les
électeurs et les autres candidats
réagissent-ils à cette énième procédure
on en débat dans 45 minutes mais d'abord
ce mot qui agite de plus en plus la
macronie
remaniement Cécile section
l'échéance des 100 jours approche et les
rumeurs vont bon train dans le camp
présidentiel comme dans les médias sur
les intentions d'Emmanuel Macron
remaniement changement de Premier
ministre que compte faire le président
de la République parce que Elisabeth
band doit apprendre l'avion fut-il vert
pour reprendre quelques jours de
vacances ou rester à Matignon selon je
souhaite
mais pour l'instant qu'elle soit la
tâche depuis longtemps possible merci
Elisabeth borne le premier celui de
Richard Ferrand en dehors du jeu
politique depuis sa défaite au
législative l'ancien président de
l'Assemblée nationale sort de sa réserve
dans une interview au Figaro et se dit
plus vétérans caspirant au poste de
Premier ministre une formule ambiguë sur
ses intentions l'autre nom évoqué celui
de François beyroux s'il actuel
commissaire au plomb se dit intéressé
pour le poste il se sait empêcher par le
procès à venir des assist par le menteur
je suis assez préoccupé par la situation
du pays pour vous dire que oui j'aurais
[Musique]
aimé assumer ce rôle cette mission et
cette responsabilité mais je suis hors
jeu l'autre option serait d'effectuer un
virage à droite et de sceller un accord
avec les républicains comme le demande
une partie des députés renaissances voir
choisir un premier ministre LR une
option non n'envisageable pour le chef
de fil de l'aile gauche du parti
présidentiel Sacha Ollier non moi je le
souhaite pas on a montré d'abord que on
pouvait voter texte par texte des
éléments j'ai l'impression qu'ils ne
veulent pas non plus et c'est d'abord
les républicains qui ne veulent pas y
compris que leurs idées soient reprises
y compris que leurs idées prédit y
compris et vous l'avez dit
[Musique]
le Parlement qui est moins présent etc
ça ne sera pas très utile donc ça fait
de la mauvaise politique être incapable
d'enchaîner sur de l'action et puis
surtout c'est épuisé les commentateurs
et les responsables politiques à en
quelque sorte désossé le Premier
ministre qui aura été nommé pendant tous
l'été donc j'avais un conseil à donner
c'est de ne pas le faire maintenant
quelques arguments
dans un instant il y a peut-être un
argument pour ne pas aller dans votre
sens et mise à part ce qui c'est
peut-être la l'occasion de sortir les
ministres les plus on va dire fatigué
carbonisés des monnaies de je pourrais
rajouter quelques amis
remaniement à minima c'est à dire
vraiment enlever ceux qui sont moins
communicants ceux qui sont plus trop à
leur place ceux qui ont des problèmes
aussi peut-être avec la justice donc ça
en fait quelques-uns sans citer de nous
on voit très bien à qui ça s'adresse
mais ça voudrait dire vraiment pas
changement de câble pas d'alliance un
remaniement pour passer l'été pour se
débarrasser un peu mais qui mettre à la
c'est ça le problème c'est que c'est
bien de retirer ces ministres qui
n'impriment pas tellement mais il y en a
pas tellement d'autres qui feraient
office de meilleures figures et de
meilleurs personnalités les grandes
personnalités qu'on connaît et qui ont
monté elles sont déjà au gouvernement
Bruno Le Maire Gérald Darmanin on peut
dire Collisée vérans aussi et monter
Gabriel Attal
Eric Dupond-Moretti un petit peu moins
mais sa personnalité compte quand même
on voit pas d'autres d'autres cartes à
jouer pour Emmanuel Macron c'est assez
compliqué pour ça alors d'habitude je
vais citer un sondage qui devient pas de
votre institution mais on s'appuiera
aussi sur sur votre baromètre tout à
l'heure mais c'est au doxa black bonne
cosmétique pour Le Figaro près des deux
tiers des Français qui demande désormais
la démission d'Elisabeth borne 63% je
vais vous avouer quelque chose ça m'a
surpris parce que ça fait des semaines
qu'on se dit plutôt que au sortir de de
six mois de bras de fer sur la réforme
des retraites c'est plutôt Emmanuel
Macron que les Français en veulent
sincèrement je suis gêné par ce type de
sondage et nous hollywhop on n'a jamais
fait d'enquête on a demandé la démission
de tel ou Tamise de tel ou tel ou telle
chef de gouvernement
[Musique]
casting même si comme vous le dit très
bien Émilie c'est vrai qu'il y a des
ministres sur les sujets qui soient au
cœur de préoccupations des Français
santé éducation grand âge logement qui
n'ont pas franchement imprimés mais ils
viennent borne n'est pas le problème
pour les Français et si j'étais un peu
dur je dirais que quand on interroge
plus largement sur le couple exécutif le
problème pour une majorité de français
même si lui aussi elle connaît une vraie
embellie son nageur c'est plus le
président que la première ministre et
puis poker homme un immense soit réussi
il faut également un effet de surprise
ça fait maintenant des jours que comment
disait close sur remaniement ou par
remaniement donc je trouve que voilà
l'idée d'un pédar mouillé était quelque
chose qui aura très peu d'effet son
opinion et quand même bien amorcé et
alors on va on se demandera d'ailleurs
pourquoi il y a tendre humeur et
pourquoi en ce moment mais Mathieu je
veux bien entendre votre analyse aussi
là-dessus puisque la question
traditionnelle que doit se poser ou vous
donner le conseil aux présidents mais
que doit se poser à un chef de
l'exécutif c'est à remaniement ok mais
pourquoi faire c'est encore aujourd'hui
au sommet de l'État alors d'habitude
quand on Roumanie au-delà de raison
technique vous savez quand il y a une
démission voilà on place juste quelqu'un
mais c'est pour une raison suivante on
va d'abord on peut vouloir changer
d'équipe et minimum on a dit un mot
parce qu'elle est usée selon une
question de casting on peut aussi
vouloir changer de politique parce qu'on
a promis les plus possibles ou parce que
ce qu'on a fait jusque-là ne marche pas
et ces talents de question de cap et
puis on peut enfin vouloir tirer les
leçons d'une crise dans un scrutin
intermédiaire et alors là c'est plutôt
une question de survie ou d'élan et puis
dans l'affaire qui nous sont concerne
mais c'est un peu tout ça à la fois
parce qu'on l'a dit le casting il a
montré ses limites le gouvernement il
était à la fois pléthorique et
anecdotique j'ai envie de dire et après
une année certes difficile mais
plusieurs ministres ont clairement
montré leur limite voir leur incapacité
à dépasser le mur du son le cap lui il
n'a peut-être pas changé dans la tête du
président mais la route pour y parvenir
tourne quand même de plus en plus à
droite ce qui pose évidemment une
question sur d'éventuelles de futurs de
potentiel ou d'impossible alliance
quand le nouvel élan enfin
[Musique]
qui est un effet de surprise réussi mais
qui en empêche pas le quinquennat de se
finir dans la
pétaudière que l'on sèche je parle du
quinquennat Hollande ensuite ça c'est je
le disais il y a des circonstances voilà
de casting ensuite dans le cas qui nous
occupe le succès du revenu en fait il
tient moins en casting qu'elle est
situation politique Emmanuel Macron aura
beau changer d'équipe en gros ça change
rien la composition du Parlement il lui
manquera toujours c'est 40 voix qui
permettraient à la majorité relative de
devenir absolu à moins et vous me voyez
venir et on va en parler que cette
majorité ne s'élargisse et où est-ce
qu'elle peut s'élargir à droite mais en
veulent-ils seulement évidemment on en
parlera et puis voilà enfin un
remaniement pardon ça ne marche pas
toujours parce que en Manu on ça
fonctionne pour que ça fonctionne mais
il faut que le nourrir le nouveau
gouvernement prenne ses marques d'une
certaine façon et donc que l'Élysée le
laisse prendre ses marques et le laisse
à la manœuvre et c'est là où je rejoins
Frédéric remplacer un gouvernement
d'exécutant par un nouveau
recouvernement d'exécutant ne changerait
absolument rien à faire si Emmanuel
Macron ne change pas aussi sa façon de
faire et là c'est sans doute plus facile
à dire qu'à faire alors ça je trouve ça
passionnant on va s'arrêter un peu là
dessus sur la méthode Macron Florent
vidéo est-ce que vous comprenez sa
stratégie aujourd'hui c'est dans la
publicité je dois avouer je plaide sans
doute un gros défaut j'ai je ne la
comprends plus c'est à dire que le
Président de la République a tenté à de
nombreuses reprises de faire une sortie
charismatique de crise c'est-à-dire il
se met sur le devant de la scène il
endosse une responsabilité fixe un cap
et il donne au gouvernement le soin de
le mettre en oeuvre donc c'était déjà un
peu surprenant à l'issue du de la
réforme des retraites parce que on
comprenait pas vraiment le cap qu'il
fixait il y avait beaucoup de recyclage
quand même du Cap précédent et il donne
une confiance très timorée à Elisabeth
borne puisque il la cite à peine dans
son discours et depuis il s'acharne à
éreinter la première ministre
c'est-à-dire que elle a un véritable
chemin de croix parsemé de rumeurs ou de
fausse rumeurs mais que le Président de
la République n'invalide jamais et il ne
la soutient que du bout des lèvres et si
on en est à faire un débat sur le
remanier moi c'est en partie à cause de
ce que vous nous écrivez c'est surtout à
cause d'Emmanuel Macron lui-même qui on
le sait très bien sous la Cinquième
République on guette la moindre faveur
ou des faveurs disaient on interprète
une disgrince et là le président de la
République clairement n'a jamais donné
des signes favorables à Elizabeth borne
tout juste lui a-t-elle lui a-t-il
renouvelé sa confiance qu'en vraiment
tout le monde estimé que il était allé
trop loin et que c'était une question
d'heures et puis par ailleurs Ina
quasiment pas soutenu ses ministres il y
a pas un déplacement du président de la
République en soutien d'une politique
menée donc c'est lui-même qui de temps
en temps fait des annonces et c'est
incompréhensible alors justement je veux
bien qu'on regarde là-dessus parce que
alors là on est vraiment dans la
stratégie de communication d'Emmanuel
Macron depuis on va dire la fin de la
réforme des retraites quand il annonce
le cap des 100 jours
il occupe le terrain on peut d'ailleurs
considérer que ça fonctionne sauf qu'il
prive d'air ces ministres à chaque
sortie c'est lui qui a enfin vous voyez
ce que je veux dire on parle de
l'affaiblissement de son équipe
gouvernementale il a sa part de
responsabilité
moi je trouve que ça stratégie
finalement j'avais des gros doute sur
les 100 jours d'apaisement et d'action
finalement c'est quand même pas mal
réussi si on regarde derrière on a quand
même la réforme des retraites on en
parle quasiment plus les décrets sont
passés l'opposition n'en n'entend plus
parler les casseroles c'est fini il
continue à boire des bières elle est
vraiment des corona il se fait son
succès donc il aurait mieux fait de
prendre une 16 64 c'était de la bière
française
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il
prend beaucoup de place il prend
beaucoup la lumière il a annoncé des
actions des plans à tout va il y a
quelques ministres quand même qui ont
participé d'ailleurs Elisabeth borne sur
la ruralité sur des choses très
concrètes très du quotidien des Français
mais en gros c'est lui qui se passe qui
occupe le terrain et moi je trouve que
c'est plutôt réussi parce que c'est
quand même plein de lumière plein de
choses qui vont dans des sens très très
variés mais ça donne l'impression
d'avancer et c'est ce qui est très
étonnant c'est qu'on pourrait croire
qu'il est dans une impasse parce que
évidemment au Parlement il se passe plus
rien parce qu'il y a pas de majorité
possible mais il arrive quand même à
avancer c'est un espèce de paradoxe qui
est en train de vivre c'est à dire qu'on
le voit avancer et sa cote de popularité
marche et en même temps il est
complètement paralysé et l'Alliance DLR
dont on va rediscuter elle est pas prête
de lui donner grand résultat moi je
trouve que ce qui est plus étonnant et
c'est ce que vous disiez Frédéric c'est
c'est le fond du fond même si il avance
on sait que peut-être les Français ont
renoncé pour le moment à s'opposer à ça
mais globalement ils sont très opposés à
cette politique donc il voit les petits
pas cette espèce de piétinement qui est
là d'action mais sur le fond ils y
croient plus ils le laissent aller tout
devant tout devant sans vraiment y
croire et il occupe le terrain pour ça
dans votre baromètre il faut Fiducial
pour Paris Match et SUD RADIO alors
c'est Edouard Philippe qui est toujours
en tête des des personnalités le le tri
alors il y a un François Hollande mais
enfin dans les anciens présidents qui
font pas grand chose voilà en général
notamment sur les composition de la
gauche c'est pas faux il a il a été
occupé le terrain pour peut-être faire
une petite concurrence à son ancien
prémice et ministre de l'Intérieur il y
a aussi racheletti la première ministre
elle est en 15e position elle progrès de
deux points Emmanuel Macron il est il
est quoi il est en progrès lui aussi oui
c'est ce que Émilie vient de dire c'est
vrai que les 100 jours ont eu comme
finalité c'est vrai avec une très forte
une très forte comment dire saturation
médiatique une très forte présence
médiatique du président qui avait fait
un mix entre un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il a un peu fait la
campagne qu'il a pas fait en mars avril
2022 et pour prendre un de ses
prédécesseurs le Sarkozy des vœux du
mois de janvier 2009 où il avait pendant
un mois pris la parole quasiment tous
les jours annoncé la fin de la publicité
sur le service public annoncé lui-même
devant ses ministres qui n'en savait à
peine la fin du juge d'instruction en
matière judiciaire c'est vrai qu'il a
été extrêmement présent et
uniquement ça a créé une sorte de
remontée il a parlé à ses soutiens il a
reconsolué son socle il a gagné par
exemple une quinzaine de points auprès
des électeurs du 10 avril 2022 il a
repris des parts de marché chez les
personnes âgées chez les cassumes dans
son électorat et dans
s'agissant des segments les moins
favorables à la réforme des retraites
les 50/4 ans les ouvriers les salariés
il y a une sorte de décrispation il a
gagné également quelques points il reste
un président structurellement un
populaire mais c'est vrai que j'ai pas
que ça s'est fait contre le gouvernement
mais ça s'est fait sans le gouvernement
et on en avait parlé ensemble une
émission il y a quelques semaines avec
un Bérengère monte c'est très
intéressant de voir que dans ces grands
de prise de parole dans ces points
presse mais il cite très rarement
féministe il sites quasiment jamais son
premier ministre c'est remise sauf Jean
Castex pour le louer c'était je crois en
2000 en 2021 et c'est vrai que c'est un
président qui est dans son couloir qui
retrouve une embellie son d'agir et
c'est vrai que c'est très rare pour un
chef de l'État qui la popularité de
connaître tes rebonds ça en fait quatre
quand même pour lui depuis 2017 mais il
y a des jugements qui restent très
envenimeux la réforme des retraites est
peut-être mise de côté mais il y a la
rancœur qui reste sur le chagrin de
travailler deux ans de plus et oui je
partage votre point de vue une sorte
d'asphyxie du gouvernement même si
Madame borne a quand même parler de
sujet très important puisqu'on en est à
se poser des questions de d'un éventuel
remaniement Florent radio est-ce qu'il y
a aussi un problème vous parliez de de
par qui les remplacé les les ministres
fatigués ou démonétisés mais est-ce
qu'il y a moins de candidats qu'avant
alors je pense qu'il y a beaucoup moins
de candidats d'abord parce que le vivier
qui existait en 2017 et 2022 il a été
largement épuisé mais est-ce que le job
fait moins rêver aussi et j'allais
j'allais venir effectivement je trouve
que quand on regarde les la manière dont
les ministres sont sortis du
gouvernement quand ils n'étaient pas
fatigué acculé mise en examen et c'était
quand même compliqué le président de la
République ne les a pas valorisé et puis
lorsque il retourne dans le privé pour
certains ils sont perclus de conflits
d'intérêt ce qui est normal et leur
sortie est scrutée commentée critiquer
ce qui fait que un ministre comme
Jebbari par exemple qui venait du privé
qui a voulu y retourner il a quand même
vécu huit mois de traverser lui donner
du désert puisqu'il a été nommé la hache
TVP c'est prononcé de manière
contrastique il est donc là et haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
politique pardon et donc en fait tous
les ministres qui viennent du privé où
tous les politiques qui viennent du
privé je pense non aucune envie d'aller
se cramer pardon de l'expression un peu
trial au gouvernement pour en plus ne
pas avoir de suite d'une carrière est-ce
que c'est si vrai que ça c'est comme
encore un jeu
c'est tout à fait juste d'abord pour le
poste de Premier ministre en tant que
tel c'est compliqué de trouver quelqu'un
vous souvenez que Emmanuel Macron a mis
beaucoup de temps il a même essuyé des
refus lors de juste après ça sa réaction
c'est vrai aussi pour les candidats dit
de la société civile au sens large quand
vous êtes chef d'entreprise c'est pas
évident d'abandonner son entreprise
entreprise pour être ministre d'autant
que vous avez quand même peu de pouvoir
quand vous êtes ministre vous êtes quand
même dans une pratique du pouvoir
extrêmement vertical donc soumis au bon
vouloir du président et puis il y a
cette question qui que vous venez
d'aborder c'est vrai la retour à la vie
professionnelle entre guillemets
peut-être compliqué c'est moins vrai en
revanche sur les bancs des députés et là
je peux vous dire que chez 250 députés
de la majorité oui il y a de quoi faire
4 5
ni qu'ils ont tous forcément une surface
politique ou médiatique forte mais en
tout cas il y a quand même chez des
jeunes députés chez des députés qui sont
là depuis 6 ans qui ont
leurs idées qui peuvent être on peut
être d'accord ou pas d'accord mais c'est
plutôt des députés qu'on travaillait les
Dossiers en tout cas ce qu'on a pu voir
dans en commission il y a ici un vivier
mais est-ce que ça fait un choc
politique est-ce que ça fait un choc
dans l'opinion est-ce que ça fait un
changement vraisemblablement pas c'est
le problème de Emmanuel Macron il n'y a
pas de banc il n'y a pas de bande
réserve il y a pas de en passant c'est
un mouvement qui s'est constitué qui a
marché avec des transsuges en attendant
ici ou là des gens venus de la gauche
des gens venus de la droite et un peu de
la société civile aujourd'hui le vivier
des transfuges ce tarie et ça devient
très compliqué que ça je pense parce que
au-delà de ça du fait qu'il y a pas de
banque il y a une question de management
vraiment c'est l'incapacité dans ce
mouvement de faire grandir des
personnalités soit elle saisissent comme
vous l'avez dit Jean Castex elle
saisisse l'occasion arriver un peu de
nulle part plutôt techno et puis tout
d'un coup il va imprimer une
personnalité avec son accent sa bonhomie
est quelque chose d'assez efficace mais
sinon une difficulté pour Emmanuel
Macron de faire grandir on en a parlé
souvent dès qu'un 1 prend trop de
lumière c'est compliqué ça lui fait de
l'ombre donc il accepte pas c'est
difficile pour lui il a essayé aussi les
ministres stars on a vu ce que ça a
donné Nicolas Hulot Roselyne Bachelot ça
a pas donné non plus ministre de la
culture des grands résultats il a essayé
les experts mais qui sont pas assez
politiques donc qui arrive pas à
naviguer dans ce monde quand même très
difficile
il y a quand même
une incapacité structurelle à manager
cette équipe parce qu'il y a du
potentiel quand même parce que le
spectre est tellement large au niveau
politique qu'on peut trouver quand même
des candidats est-ce que c'est
typique des manuel Macron ou constitutif
de du fonctionnement de la 5e République
très verticale finalement ce que vient
de décrire les appels ski je pense qu'il
y a des spécificités liées à cet arrivée
au pouvoir en 2017 qui était un récit
qui était parce que la gauche au pouvoir
a échoué la droite au pouvoir échouer
prenons plutôt ce gouvernement des
experts répondre à cette imaginaire de
prendre des experts des spécialistes une
sportive au sport un DRH à l'emploi etc
mais sans comment dire capital politique
et sans incarnation de la fonction en
2022 il a essayé de faire pareil c'est
vrai que vous avez raison de le dire ça
a été extrêmement long ce gouvernement
alors on sait pourquoi il veut Ludovic
vigogne Catherine Vautrin ou pas ils
aident comme deuxième choix mais c'est
vrai que comment dire la déstructuration
du politique la fin de la bipolarisation
la fin de camp très structuré le
gouvernement de Nicolas Sarkozy François
Fillon en 2007 et celui de François en
2012 se ressemble beaucoup alors en 2007
il y a quand même bien sûr à gauche en
2012 il y a pas la moindre ouverture il
y a au contraire une version vers les
candidats battus de la primaire Arnaud
Montebourg Manuel Valls voir presque
Martin lombric on a supplié de prendre
un grand ministère de l'Éducation
nationale rien de tel pour Emmanuel
Macron problème de banc problème de
figure politique forte et on le on le
voit dans le baromètre que vous citiez
il y a de 15 dernières places 9 ou 10
ministres qui ne sont pas connus par 6 à
7 Français sur 10 donc difficile après
de porter des politiques et un sujet
supplémentaire c'est que les gens n'ont
pas d'autonomie de pensée ou d'autonomie
politique à gauche Xavier des gens qui
incarnaient les courants de la gauche à
droite des gens qui incarnaient les
familles de la droite là il y a pas
comme c'est un mouvement en construction
en jeunesse c'est difficile et c'est
d'autant plus difficile que personne ne
connaît le catéchisme le seul qui
connaît le catéchisme c'est Emmanuel
Macron non mais ça ça rend les choses
c'est compliqué pour exister
politiquement parce que du coup vous
resserrez mécaniquement sur vos dossiers
parce que quand vous êtes interrogé par
des journalistes que vous êtes mises aux
éducation nationale et que vous êtes
interrogé sur l'industrie sur
l'immigration ou sur l'insécurité mais
vous sortez pas de votre couloir parce
que vous ne savez pas quoi dire avec
quand même il y a peut-être que la plus
macroniste de tous et de toutes c'est
justement la première ministre c'est
Florent maillot je sais pas si vous êtes
d'accord avec cette idée mais ce serait
encore plus injuste finalement de de la
sortir du jeu aussi vite quoi je trouve
que elle a le profil idéal pour être
première ministre d'Emmanuel Macron il
est temps de se rendre compte oui oui
mais d'abord elle a résisté à Ségolène
Royal ce qui est en général est une
école qui permet de résister à beaucoup
de tempêtes c'est de dire que ça durcit
le cuir je pense que ça durcit le cuir
et ça va jusque jusqu'au muscle mon sens
ensuite elle a elle mène une politique
quand même qui est très proche des
républicains parce que il y a peu de
texte sur lesquels les républicains ont
des quatre consciences majeur hormis en
termes de stratégie politique et en même
temps elle rassure l'aile gauche de la
macronie qu'il ne faut pas oublier parce
que plus on souffle oui c'est
intéressant on peut plaire aux
républicains sans perdre l'aile gauche
c'est un peu l'objectif quand on voit
que Clément beau de monter au au front
et Sacha Oullier le président de la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale montée au front pour dire qu'à
la première ministre devrait rester
parce qu'elle est finalement le plus
petit des Namur commun c'est quand même
le signe que après elle le mouton à 5
pattes va être compliqué à trouver
d'autant que le Président de la
République a tellement maltraité
l'Assemblée nationale qu'il n'y a pas de
figure parlementaire qui émerge
véritablement il y a de temps en temps
des des points de focale comme le
président de la commission des lois mais
quelles autres parlementaires sont en
mesure de devenir de grands ministres un
mot là dessus
pour corroborer ce que vous dites je
suis frappé de voir que l'équation
personnelle l'image d'un Premier
ministre reste bonne auprès des Français
à l'image de sérieux d'intelligence
quelqu'un qui est technicienne mais au
bon sens du terme alors ce qui est en
revanche pour elle c'est que le point
critique c'est les 49-3 d'ailleurs elle
commence à baisser dans de popularité
avant la réforme des retraites lorsque à
l'automne 2022 elle utilise 9 ou 8 ou 9
49.3 et ce qui est frappant également
par rapport à Édouard Philippe et agent
Castex c'est que aucune mesure forte ne
lui est attachée la réforme des
retraites C Emmanuel Macron en dehors de
ça elle ne tient ce socle de 30-35 %,
c'est son image personnelle et comme
vous le dites ce côté ce plus petit des
médiateur commun entre l'algor et l'aile
droite de la macronie alors un autre
élément de de sondage toujours pour Le
Figaro ce chiffre 56% des Français se
disent favorables à un accord de
gouvernement avec les républicains voilà
le camembert illustrant ce sondage et on
va en parler tout de suite avec Quentin
calmé qui veut peut nous rejoindre sur
son plateau bonsoir Quentin bonsoir à
tous volonté en tout cas selon ce
sondage des des français sauf que c'est
pas si simple et les cadres du parti LR
on redit le refus c'était ce weekend
tout à fait alors le point de départ de
cette rumeur Thomas c'est une situation
à la majorité de la situation de la
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale de leur
parler d'ailleurs Mathieu il manque à
l'exécutif une quarantaine de députés
pour disposer d'une majorité absolue or
elle est députés LR sont là ils sont 62
un remaniement qui pencherait à droite
pourrait permettre ainsi d'avoir une
stabilité dans les musiques de
l'Assemblée nationale d'autant que les
LR sont compatibles politiquesment avec
la macronie sur certains sujets
notamment les sujets économiques
rappelez-vous la réforme des retraites
c'est une version de la réforme proche
de celle des sénateurs que les sénateurs
votaient même depuis 2019 qui avait été
présenté et évidemment beaucoup de noms
issus de LR qui circule pour Matignon
j'ai peut-être que vous l'avez vu hier
dans le Journal du Dimanche et on voyait
la photo de Laurent Wauquiez dans un
entre filet effectivement le journal
raconte que ses proches lui ont soumis
cette idée en échange Emmanuel Macron
l'adoubret ensuite pour lui succéder à
l'Elysée un deal finalement écarté car
beaucoup trop risqué et puis il y a un
autre nom qui revient régulièrement
celui du président du Sénat Gérard voilà
c'est vrai que le gouvernement se tourne
de plus en plus vers le Sénat depuis les
dernières législatives depuis un an ce
sont déjà neuf projets de loi qui ont
d'abord été inscrits à l'ordre du jour
du Sénat avant leur examen à l'Assemblée
nationale mais le principal intérêt à
redit qu'il n'était pas question
d'alliance écouter j'ai un lycée ce
samedi aux états généraux de la droite
il est même et bien même aller en un
cran plus loin que ce à quoi nous avait
habitué
je reste convaincu je vous le dis que la
bonne stratégie doit être l'indépendance
et la responsabilité
cette majorité relative n'est pas la
nôtre nos différences sont très
profondes mais ce samedi on a entendu
d'autres personnalités évoqué cette
alliance il faudrait pour cela qu'il
manuellement Macron et bien change de
braquer notamment sur les sujets
régaliens écouter le sénateur LR Roger
caoutchi nous venons nous proposer des
textes sur l'immigration si le président
de la République dit banco je suis pas
allé mettre en application si vous
acceptez un pacte sur des projets
immigration sécurité éducation on peut
réfléchir mais si c'est juste pour faire
du débauchage non voilà Roger carochi
qui était un proche de Nicolas Sarkozy
il a été membre de deux de ses
gouvernements on sait qu'en coulisse
l'ancien président de la République et
bien il a été très actif il serait très
actif pour faire en sorte que la
macronie se rapproche DLR de son côté le
modem et l'aile gauche de renaissance
freine des quatre fers merci beaucoup
Quentin Mathieu pourquoi il y avait un
ensuite Laurent Wauquiez qui sort de la
fin j'ai cherché moi je suis toujours
surprise une partie de billards mais à
14 ans
n'a pas voulu la jouer c'est en fait
quand vous avez une atmosphère de
remaniement mais c'est le grand jeu du
nom qui circule généralement les noms
qui circulent sont pas toujours les bons
ça peut mais pas toujours les bons et
puis mais il faut en être il faut en
être parce que sinon vous n'existez pas
et Laurent Wauquiez lui opté pour une
stratégie de retrait depuis un an il
s'est peut-être très éloigné du
confideur Traite soit disant
eriki devait lui préparer une piste
d'atterrissage ou une rampe de lancement
selon ce qu'on choisit à LR et et il n'a
pas joué le jeu Laurent Wauquiez et sur
la question des retraites il a été
filéreux il a fait voter contre certains
députés de de sa région et aujourd'hui
pour revenir dans le jeu il a fait une
grande interview au point qui n'a
intéressé que l'évoqueristes et donc il
va falloir trouver autre chose donc
c'est juste de la présence médiatique
c'est à mon avis la seule le seul
intérêt de cette équation
que cette rumeur Laurent Wauquiez à
Matignon traduit aussi l'état du champ
politique dans la perspective de 2027 on
nous avons une tripartition entre une ce
que je peux ce que j'ai appelé la guerre
la guerre des trois blocs le bloc lui
pèse le bloc à Rennes et un bloc central
ce bloc central il y a la majorité il y
a le modèle horizon Renaissance mais où
se trouvait l'air dans cette
tripartition dans cette guerre des trois
blocs et c'est la théorie de Nicolas
Sarkozy il l'a dit il l'a fait dire que
LR ne peut être que dans le bloc central
donc si on pousse cette logique jusqu'au
bout alors qu'il faut attendre les
sénatoriales email Macron ne peut que
nommer quelqu'un de chez LR pour que
elle rentre dans le bloc central et se
disent en 2027 pour l'investiture pour
le candidat ou la candidate de l'eau
centrale on jouera le match face au
modem horizon ça paraît un peu incongru
à 4 en du vote mais dans ce cadre là
dans le cadre de cette guerre des trois
blocs je vous pose la question et moi je
vous repose la question si vous êtes
passé très vite sénatorial ça pour vous
ça peut pas avoir lieu avant les
sénatoriales de de septembre quand on
parle du général archer quand on parle
d'un débauchage important de
personnalité de r on se dit mais vous
savez on l'a dit au début le remaniement
ça doit surprendre qui est oreille
imaginé dans le peuple si je puis dire
que François Mitterrand congé dirait
Michel Rocard en 1991 alors c'était un
prémisse archi populaire pareil pour
Édouard Philippe en 2020 donc la
surprise doit être là mais
rationnellement sur le sur le papier on
imagine pas quelqu'un comme Gérard
lâcher bouger une oreille avant le 23 24
septembre Émilie moi je m'interroge sur
le sondage sur les Français qui
souhaitent je trouve que ça ça porte
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire est-ce que ça
veut pas dire aussi que les Français ont
envie de choses claires parce qu'ils ont
un en même temps qui va un peu à droite
qui va un peu à gauche dont on voit les
limites avec des projets de loi comme
sur l'immigration
d'ailleurs pas mal de sujets finalement
on voit bien que ça ça débouche sur rien
on a peut-être l'impression que les
Français sont plutôt intéressés par un
clivage gauche-droite qui remettrai les
choses en place on voit bien que de
toute façon là vous avez donné la partie
des républicains mais chez Emmanuel
Macron faire une alliance avec les LR
c'est la fin du en même temps et tout ça
pour un potentiel de moins de 5% à la
présidentielle 2022 ça serait quand même
retirer son projet dû en même temps pour
très peu de choses faire beaucoup de
concessions pour en plus des gens qui
seraient pas forcément très fiables pour
assurer une majorité aux différents
textes moi je vois pas tellement ces
tissus mais je trouve que c'est
intéressant que les Français se
signalent comme ça ça veut dire que
quelque part peut-être qu'il n'y croit
pas en même temps qu'ils ont pas
accroché sur ce projet qui c'est vrai
piétine un peu en tout cas sur le plan
pratique peut-être sur le plan théorique
il est très joli mais sur le plan
pratique il ne le voit pas et ils n'y
mettent pas un sou finalement pour le
Premier ministre Florent radio il y a un
juge de paix qui est toujours le vote du
budget c'est le moment où on va enfin
voilà à ce moment là il faut se
positionner très clairement pour ou
contre la la majorité au pouvoir qui
présente un budget et donc c'est
compliqué quand on ne vote pas un budget
n'en suis ensuite d'aller expliquer
qu'on est pour certaines politiques
publiques qui sont financées par le
budget qui a été refusé donc c'est un
une difficulté sans nom et et je pense
d'ailleurs que la première année
d'ambiguïté et on écoutait Gérard
Larcher qui disait en gros on a des des
accords profonds mais quand il faut on
vote les textes donc c'est un peu
contradictoires donc cette première
année d'ind distinction elle a été
rendue facile par
l'attitude de la nupesse à l'Assemblée
nationale enfin de la lsfit l'Assemblée
nationale et par la réforme des
retraites qui en fait les républicains
pouvaient en quelque sorte louvoyer
parce que personne n'y comprenait rien
et personne savait de quel côté ça
allait tomber là je pense que les quatre
années qui vont venir vont être très
compliqué pour tenir cette position
durablement de je vote ce qui m'arrange
je vote pas le sénat et l'assemblée sont
pas d'accord cagoule et le projecteurs
sont beaucoup plus braqués sur les LR
sincèrement d'autant que
ocinatorial le président l'archet et
normalement il doit être renouvelé
puisque les Yvelines font partie des des
sénateurs qui doivent être renouvelés
donc et ensuite il sera réélu ou pas on
verra ce que fait François Patriat et le
groupe des macronistes si votre ou pas
pour Gérard Larcher et puis ensuite il
va y avoir les Européennes et les euros
c'est dans un an dans un an oui mais
c'est ça va être un élément de
clarification assez intéressant pour la
gauche bien sûr mais aussi pour la
droite pour le les macronistes parce que
les macronistes ils ont un thème sur les
progressistes qui se va bien avec la
question des européennes mais on verra
si on a une repolarisation à partir de
ce moment-là et ça sera compliqué pour
les républicains à ce moment alors c'est
intéressant parce que on le sait il y a
Nicolas Sarkozy qui qui essaye de
pousser des des candidats qui souhaitent
un accord avec Heller c'est pas nouveau
ça il y a un nom qui ressort
régulièrement du chapeau c'est celui de
son ancienne ministre de l'Économie
devenu président de la Banque centrale
européenne Christine Lagarde fréque
d'habit est-ce qu'elle est la sortie du
des radars de l'opinion de l'opinion
publique française Christine Lagarde ou
pas d'ailleurs clairement je le pense je
pense car elle a plus d'activité dans le
champ politique national depuis 2012 si
je me trompe pas depuis la victoire à
l'alternance la victoire de François
Hollande elle avait c'est vrai sur
l'époque de l'air Sarkozy une très forte
popularité qui était pas comment dire
des éléments forts mais par une image
sérieux d'expertise une sorte de
proximité admirative c'est quelqu'un qui
en jetait si je puis dire mais voilà
elle a quand même très largement disparu
des radars et c'est dur dans ce champ
politique atone dans un contexte il faut
le dire de défiance des Français de plus
en plus fort vis-à-vis du champ et du
personnel politique il y a 10 ans
puisqu'on reprend sur 2012 il y avait 22
personnalités dans le baromètre il faut
Fiducial pour mâcher Sud Radio qui avait
une majorité de bonnes opinions en
septembre 2007 il n'avait plus cuite là
il y en a plus qu'une et vous le disiez
il n'y a que Édouard Philippe ça en dit
non seulement
tout le monde et voir sur la barre des
carences avec le 4 personnalités qui ont
plus de 40%, il y en avait une trentaine
en 2012 donc c'est quelqu'un qui pourra
apparaître comme un recours une bonne
surprise il y a pas d'éléments d'image
il y a pas de cadavres dans le placard
si je puis dire la concernant mais ça
reste aujourd'hui je pense un scénario
de science-fiction d'autre le seul
intérêt d'un ministre de droite
issu du LR Macron aujourd'hui c'est
quelqu'un qui fasse voter
comme un seul homme et sous Christine
Lagarde aujourd'hui de là où elle est à
autorité sur le groupe LR je ne pense
pas le groupe LR le problème c'est que
elle les rappelle à un accord ce qu'on
entend de la voie de Roger caoutchi mais
les LR n'ont pas de parole c'est ce que
on a vu avec la la crise des retraites
donc comment vous direz avec des gens
qui n'ont pas de parole et après il y a
ce problème de l'indifférenciation c'est
vrai ils sont coincés entre la macronie
qui leur a tout pris du point de vue
économique
sociale une réforme des retraites qui
est que qu'il portait de qu'ils
appelaient de leurs vœux depuis
plusieurs années et il y a cette extrême
droite qui qui leur prend toutes les
idées sur le régalien ou en tout cas
dont il pique toutes les idées LR sur le
régalien notamment les migration
l'insécurité la bonne tactique
semble-t-il s'ils étaient trop de ski
ces gens-là ils montraient dans l'avion
pour le détourner parce que l'avion de
la macronie on a dit il y a pas beaucoup
de pilotes ni de copilote et c'est là
que ça se passe mais c'est sûr que pour
eux c'est franchi le Rubicon et c'est
perdre des définitivement la partie sur
la droite c'est accepter que toute la
politique soit compose et qu'il jette le
bébé avec l'eau du bain vers le
gaullisme le scénariste
ils vont sortir quand même plutôt
gagnant il y a l'éventualité du budget
de motion de censure il y a peut-être
ils ont encore besoin de montrer leurs
muscles avant de pouvoir négocier
peut-être quelque chose de plus gros
mais idéologiquement
radio je sais pas entre un olivier
Marleix et un Édouard Philippe est-ce
qu'il y a tant de différence que ça sur
le sur le fond sur ce qui je pense que
il y a très peu de différence alors on
peut il peut y avoir des tonalités
on est à 50 nuances peut-être au jeu des
7 des 7 erreurs
à des problèmes sociologiques et
personnels c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui
les députés LR ils ont été élus dans
leur circonscription contre Emmanuel
Macron ils ont fait quand même contre
donc ils ont un moment donné leur
positionnement politique serait
incohérent et puis ce qui reste et ce
qui pourrait travailler ensemble donc de
l'extérieur on trouverait ça normal
c'est un Bruno Le Maire Gérald Darmanin
Édouard Philippe il se détestent tous
c'est-à-dire que Olivier Marleix quand
on lui parle d'Edouard Philippe il fait
des bons sur sa chaise en disant il nous
a trahi au pire moment quand Alain Juppé
a perdu les primaires et ensuite il
s'est vendu et donc en réalité il y a
des questions moins politiques que
sociologiques et personnel ce sont des
haines recuites qui font que ces gens
n'ont pas envie de travailler ensemble
vous avez raison sur les élus les
personnalités mais quand on regarde dans
toute une série d'enquêtes les
sympathisants LR et les sympathisants
Renaissance sur les questions
économiques sur les questions de
l'Europe on a vraiment des convergences
très fortes je dirais même parler de en
2017 où il y a eu un soutien LR à
l'époque s'appelait lrem soirée fente de
la SNCF sur la première réforme des
retraites sous la réforme de du code et
des lois travail par contre les
questions régaliennes oui les
sympathisants en essence regardent plus
vers la gauche et c'est dans ce cas-là
que l'électorat LR est en fusion avec
lectorat RN donc c'est aussi ce problème
de tiraillement et comme vous le disiez
d'espace politique absolument compliqué
pour LR ça se passe ça se passe chez
l'air ça se passe à droite ou est-ce que
ça se passe exactement aujourd'hui la
droite dans cet espace et dans cette
guerre des trois blocs alors on se
posait la question de de de la
profondeur de banc il y a quand même des
personnalités évidemment qui l'ont sur
Matignon notamment des projets manuel
Macron Richard Ferrand par exemple
l'ancien président l'Assemblée nationale
qui dans le Figaro ce week-end répond à
la question votre nom est cité pour
Matignon aspirez-vous à revenir au
gouvernement il répond je suis plutôt un
vétéran qu'un aspirant s'agissant des
rumeurs tout ce qui flotte les Gaulois
avec circonspection et reconnaissance
préférons à ces questions personnelles
la quête de réponse à celle qui concerne
le destin de la France et l'avenir des
Français les défis de l'époque et du
monde nous ferions là œuvres utiles bon
voilà Richard Ferrand
je vois pas vraiment le nouveau souffle
hein Mathieu non alors c'est un élément
un élément clé du dispositif d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est à dire que Emmanuel Macron
a besoin de Richard Ferrand qui
n'existait pas politiquement Emmanuel
Macron c'est pas lui faire un jour de
dire que ça jamais été une personnalité
politique de poids de force aux parties
socialiste ni en Bretagne ni au niveau
national mais dans l'écosystème
macronien ça a été une référence parce
que un politique blanchi sur le harnais
un élu local dans un pouvoir qui ne
connaissait pas beaucoup les élus locaux
voilà après est-ce que c'est un poids
lourd pour les Français je ne suis pas
persuadé et Frédéric peut nous le dire
je pense que le taux de notoriété de
Richard Ferrand en avril 2022 lorsque
juste avant sa défaite protection
législatives il y avait je crois 5
Français sur 10 qui déclaraient une pâle
connaître suffisamment c'est lié au fait
que la scène parlementaire et c'est
dommage est une scène peu visible madame
Pivet ce même problème de notoriété qui
n'est pas nul loin de là mais une image
qui est pas complètement assise auprès
des Français puis alors dans cette même
interview et je trouve ça quand même
très intéressant en creux de ce que ça
révèle il agite l'hypothèse d'une
révision constitutionnelle pour
autoriser un troisième mandat consécutif
Florent radio ça dit quand même la
macronie qui est incapable de se
projeter dans la prime Macron enfin
voilà c'est c'est ça l'histoire je pense
que le vrai problème c'est que la
macronie est morte 100 Emmanuel Macron
parce que le jour où Emmanuel Macron
n'est plus le régulateur des tensions
l'aile droite reprendra ses négociations
avec la droite et l'aile gauche qui déjà
était déjà en train de le faire
reprendra des ces discussions avec les
parties de gauche qui lui sont
compatibles et c'est deux courants
attendent l'appel d'air en fait
exactement en fait c'est Manuel Macron
c'est il s'est un régulateur des
tensions et donc pour l'instant il y a
un plonger il y a une incarnation et
donc ça peut passer encore mais le jour
où il disparaît il disparaît
politiquement j'entends évidemment
chacun va reprendre ses billes parce que
ceux qui voudront continuer une carrière
politique devront bien se trouver un
destin et un sponsor et dans ce cas-là
les sponsors et soit ils seront créés
soit ils existeront et le seul avantage
de ce point de vue là que Richard
Ferrand présente pour maintenir c'est
que c'est le seul à avoir un vrai sens
politique et être capacité de
négociation il a pas forcément montré
quand il était présent à l'assemblée
nationale mais il a un sens de la
négociation et il a ouvert dans son
interview Figaro finalement il dit faut
pas changer de ligne de gouvernement il
faut juste que vous acceptiez des
compromis raisonnables de part et à
gauche et à droite donc finalement il
est exactement mais il veut être le
l'ultra de du macronisme moi j'ai
l'impression quand même que cette petite
sortie là sur 3e mandat c'est aussi un
petit peu pour faire plaisir aux grands
chefs pour lui donner un avenir enfin il
y a un petit côté comme ça parce qu'il
s'est rattrapé c'est pas une erreur
politique quand même là
en disant oui je parlais pas de 2027 et
ridicule enfin
alors que tous les médias a quand même
tous les médias ont quand même compris
ça oui il a parlé de moutons de panure
mais moi je trouve que c'est quand même
alors évidemment qu'il va faire du du
Elisabeth borne s'il était élu il y a
rien de nouveau mais par contre oui le
renouveau puis les affaires quand même
même si ça a été c'est prescrit je crois
que les affaires qu'il a sur les
mutuelles mais enfin on a quand même les
anciens probablement peuvent rassurer
Emmanuel Macron comme il avait au début
Gérard Collomb des gens qui connaissent
bien mais alors le renouveau bonjour
puis un peu de froid entre Emmanuel
Macron et Richard Ferrand
puisqu’emmanuel Macron avait proposé à
Richard Ferrand d'entrée à l'Elysée et
Richard Ferrand lui avait répondu tu me
vois être le collaborateur d'Alexis
colère donc c'est ça la sortie de piste
n'a pas été extrêmement bien gérée pour
Richard Ferrand on va terminer là dessus
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir participé à
ce débat qui était passionnant je vous
dis à bientôt sur public